no way
[Music]
there's no way and I can't stun him
what's wrong with you all right so if
you remember the last time we left off
our buddy
professor egad who's really kind of a
jerk I mean he he really is I mean I
guess you could say he's one of those
stereotypical scientists who doesn't
really care about about others and
really only cares about his studies
which you know not a very personable guy
let's just put it that way
[Music]
yo buddy many many missing something
here oh wait
oh that's nice
look at that
[Music]
oh this guy what in the world
it's like a y'all won't for Mario ODL
dude all right all right all right what
do we have
gotta get in the back
yeah sure HP it's all right we're
slamming him though we're slamming him
like nothing come on show yourself back
got you Ken
[Music]
he's like a terrified security guard
well let's be friends dude I'm packed
for the frederigo no oh I don't like
this guy he has got a weapon though chat
all right you know we got to go Luigi oh
it's a water gun so we got to be careful
no oh no no I keep forgetting there's so
many controls this game honestly
still in dim get a bunch of slams in
good slams good slam squeegee areas
there is a look at him they're ready to
go kiss me from across the room that
name do that
aim yeah keep shooting outside slow like
that so we're gonna get close to you I'm
gonna do this right here we're gonna Oh
Judi was ready for that one
oh there's no way he had the shades on
gotcha
now that time I'm quick on the draw bro
yeah so much for feeling sorry for you
yeah I want you to look I want you to
look I mean I mean is this I thought
this was a kids game
[Music]
I thought this
that is that is what I think it is right
that that is the the rear end of a pig
I do believe just just there just there
for all of us to see it is indeed chat
confirmed could we have confirmed that
it is indeed is there anything more to
this it going really fast yo it's like
ham from Toy Story sporting all the
money don't you think you would
eventually get used to ghosts like have
you ever seen this meeting but if I if I
have a ghost just literally came and
loose room right now I would freak out I
would freak out then if some dude like
came in and he's like oh here's a one
vacuum cleaner that can kill the earth
they can take these go you know the
second one would still probably freak me
out
the third one a little bit but then like
once you once you're on your fourth goes
get rid of that cheese
what's your own like your fourth ghost
don't you think that the beer would wear
off a little bit especially if all they
try to do Coast like throw food at me
what if we get both of them going yeah
yeah one is there a park somewhere
art art art anywhere we get one more
time it's over chat me if one more time
it's over dee dee runs faster when he's
not holding the fish we got him we got
him concentrate concentrate
[Music]
and the widget comes out on top be sure
to get that follow button before he
leaves in the top right corner and a
little heart great way to support the
stream and we do this thing every Monday
Wednesday Friday oh you know that cheese
you remember that cheese
you remember that cheese are you serious
I don't want the cheese I don't want the
cheese you have to wait let it eat the
cheese okay yeah I'm gonna have him
where he is look right on where the
mouse is gonna go right on it dude
no way there's no way there's no way
there's no way this is really driving me
crazy-like you go over that far to get
it he will and I can't stun him
[Applause]
[Music]
no freakin way do another Mouse these
ghosts I think they're misunderstood
there's only a couple of them at the top
of the of the food chain so to speak
they've corrupted all these other goats
Jay I mean these other ghosts like that
security guard he was just trying to do
a job okay I guess we're just gonna
leave these dudes here you have to leave
them I'm to leave them alive right now
Luigi can take the elevator and on we go
yeah yeah I don't forget all that insane
like share subscribe comment send to
your friends and family post it on your
wall
done